everybody stop action episode 8 gosh
the first film didn't even have a number
Ryan has written a story that's
unexpected but right
[Music]
some of the stuff that happens people
without oh my god
even though I think I know it all they
throw things at me story wise I never
could have imagined and even though
everybody knows it's the second in the
trilogy it feels like its own thing
go
powers are so cool because there's all
these creatures probably the main visual
effects
like all the characters are also so
complex Ryan mr. workers will keep out
ah to the new director television to
learn or to terms it feels like the
storylines became more established we're
really getting to know these new
characters all thing with the characters
that we know and love
within their lives change
everything is being shifted in a
positive way for what you'll get
expected after seven bridesmaids star
was fresh in you
[Music]
I'm hoping it'll be a little shocking
but I'm hoping it'll feel real and
honest
for my ancient story of fit against evil
told in the most [ __ ] mate same way it
had a real spiritual death today
it's about family and that's what's so
powerful about it
you